The joe rogan experience,
you're thinking,
I want people to spend 30 40 bucks to
go out and that'd be pissed him off and
ruin your night with your wife for a date.
No,
really end up just trying to make you
laugh. So now it's like, you know it,
it's just so Joe, I can remember back
with you and Mike McCarthy. Yeah,
it was like who could work the dirtiest?
You guys would be in the back just dying.
There were nights made,
can't even get high and say,
let's see if we can walk the room
and I've seen people suck and have a roof,
but I mean women that we'd,
we'd love that.
Oh my God.
I remember one night I was doing great
and I said that let me get fucked up.
And I turned on the crowd and then I
felt bad because they will so upset.
So discuss with him and he's like,
regulars usually come.
I started trying to win him
back with a bank I took,
took me an hour and a half
just to get them back.
But there was another dude
I showed I'll head over.
There was a guy heckle him and I
said, listen, if you don't shut up,
I'm going to come down here puppy
right in the fucking face. And I did.
I went and went off the stage and up this
fucking guy where he was bleeding and
I mean,
and the crowd was on his son.
He's attacking us and it took me
45 minutes just to break even,
you know? And then you kept going after
you punched the guy in the face. Yeah.
That's amazing. You didn't know.
No God. Alando I don't know why.
I know it wasn't linear. It was, you know,
I was doing a bunch of one
night isn't it with and I was,
because the crowd was a big crowd,
but it's been like 300 people and they
all love being away and this guy just,
and I fucking hate it. I wouldn't
write a, put the mic down,
Bang went off and he went down.
He was screaming and crying. Wow.
And I went up in a bipolar, that's
the difference in Boston and Orlando.
But you didn't think that he was lying?
I suspected he wasn't
telling us the whole truth,
but I thought he made some interesting
points in Alpha to Alfred had was a
pitcher in high school,
North Miami Beach,
senior high go chargers and Alfred had
actually pitched against Alex Rodriguez.
This is like one of his only more stories
from his baseball years in high school,
right is that Alex was
a senior at the Alpha,
was going to some sort of Ron Frasier,
a baseball camp,
had a u m and they did the
summer league game and Alfred,
this is my eyes are glazing
over telling the story,
but like Alfred Alfred pitches against
a ride and who was already a senior
already a beast.
Everybody knew this guy was going to,
was going to go in the draft and be huge.
Everybody knew about that.
He had been the talk of the high school
baseball community in Miami forever and
so Alfred pitched against him
and he held a rod to a triple.
Of course, Alec, you know a red smacked
the shit out of this ball, sailed away,
but he alphabet, he was, it was only
a triple. It wasn't, it was a rare,
not home run for Alex. So I thought, oh,
we have like a funny personal anecdote.
Like we can find some common ground here,
right?
You're talking to someone who might be
a potential interview subject, you know?
And so I'm like,
actually Alex,
you and Alfred have met
before Alpha rolls his eyes.
Like he's going to embarrass me
and tell this dumb shit story.
So I tell out like,
isn't this funny?
Like you guys met and Alfred held you
to a triple and he kind of looked at me
like, you're looking at
me right now. He's just,
he was totally on amused and maybe
looked even a little hurt or offended.
Oh Wow.
This is the greatest baseball,
one of the greatest baseball
players of all time,
the highest paid baseball
player in history.
And here I'm just telling this cute story
from like 20 years earlier or whatever.
And he seemed like I held me to a triple.
I'm like,
how could you be upset about that?
You one of the greatest of all time super
winners, but it's like, yeah, it's the,
it's, it's, that's why I left. I was like,
this guy's a really interesting character.
Like he's a complicated guy.
He's an interesting guy. He's a sensitive
guy. Like I was curious about him.
I was excited about the prospect
of interviewing him and man,
they practically ghosted us
out. Yeah. The January of 2014,
that's when they lowered,
they reduce the suspension.
I started hitting up every month.
I started hitting up the publicists yo
following up on that meeting. You know,
cause it's funny,
in the page six article it mentioned
he met with the 30 for 30 filmmakers,
Billy Corbin output Spellman.
Uh,
he's been shopping a book
proposal to these publishers.
The book proposal thing was total
bunk. Literally not true. The, the,
the publishers were like,
we'd love to get one,
but we haven't gotten a
book proposal from a Rod.
He really did have the meeting with
us. But like, so everything was just,
we were just kind of pawns in his game,
which is cool.
Whatever they respond to this documentary.
Not exactly,
but I for only six or seven months,
I'm emailing with the publicist and
then it was clear that they weren't
interested. So, and that
became the tactic. By the way,
when you said was there a strategy,
the strategy was to shut the fuck up.
We have evidence again in the
archaeological records of,
of surgical procedures going far back.
But who did them?
They would have been um,
you know, sometimes why they
call them wise women comedy.
Connie women on marver
surgeons. So one of my, yeah,
with the barber, I guess they're
good razors, right? Yes. Yeah.
Actually Barbara surgeons used to
do things like pull your teeth.
They used to blood, sweat.
And so the Barber Pole,
which is right in white is right and
white because it was advertising their
services is blood letters.
So what they would do,
they would tie these bloody rags around
the pole and it would whip around the
pole. I know it's one of my
favorite stories. And, um,
and the,
the ball at the top represented the
bowl that would catch the blood and the
stick would have been the stick that you
held to kind of get your veins to stick
out and people were blood
let for all kinds of reasons.
Like you would do it like
a purge or a diet or,
or you would do it because you were ill.
Um,
the idea being that you had produced too
much blood and you needed the blood to
be let to kind of restore
balance in your body.
What do you think it would be like to
go back in time and hear someone say
something that's stupid?
Like, you're sick.
We need to remove some of your glove.
Do you have too much blood in your system?
Z show you're going to send all of these
like crazy academic historians are like,
we can't. Yeah, there you go.
There Tom Sorial services.
What does that mean?
And you know what else?
The barber shop quartet comes from the
idea that the barber surgeons often had a
musical loot in the office that you
would play or the patient would play.
It was like a musical therapy. Um, so
there's all kinds of hangovers from it.
And you know, the demon barber, a
Sweeney Todd. Yeah. So this is kind of a,
one of these stories that pops up and
they think that it might be that medical
practitioners were trying to undermine
the legitimacy of the barbers.
So you kind of either get
this story that the barber,
is this like sort of demon figure who's
chopping you up in selling you and
making you into pies?
Or
is that a legit one?
Because that seems like nonsense.
Well it seems like it's a recreation of,
it's an older one cause well it
seems like parody, like look says,
listen to my troubles. No charge.
Listen to your troubles. 50 cents.
They might've had that on there.
Barbered thing when they're
cutting bolts out of you,
it's this bullets removed two bucks. I
don't know. They're all drunk. Pomade,
mustache wax.
Yeah. People, people thought that bullets
were, uh, that gunpowder was poisonous.
So a surgeon would often amputate
if you were shot. Oh God.
Until they kind of realize that sometimes
it was okay to just keep the bullet in.
I am a firm believer that many of us who
are feeling really good about life and
having a great time here are v very,
very lucky in their
circumstance. Very lucky in, in,
in the people you're around,
the positive influences in your life,
the good things,
very lucky cause shit can be really not
good and when things are really not good
and people go down the spiral,
whether it's with booze and cigarettes
and heroin or whether it's with food or
whether it's with alcohol or
whether it's whatever, the pills,
if you can go down a spiral,
it's who out of the person that is in
the bottom of the spiral who can pull
themselves out.
Could you,
if you had to start from there instead
of starting from a place of success,
and this is why I think people get cocky.
You wake up every morning like, oh,
I guess everything's okay.
You know my lifestyle and the share.
Instead think of what it would be like
if you woke up and you were 380 pounds
and this is your new life.
Your new life is you got to get down
from 380 pounds to about 220 pounds.
You got to figure out how to do that
and you've got to figure out how to not
lapse. When you're aching with hunger.
You got to figure out how, how your, your,
your body has no fucking energy.
It doesn't know how to recover.
It never gets pushed.
And you have to push it through that and
you have to do that to the tune of 160
pounds. It's a lot of fucking weight, man.
That's a lot of fucking
weight. Most people are not
going to be able to do that.
It's a lot of weight to lose.
How long that take you? Um,
about how two and a half years.
That's a,
no matter what, that's an
accomplishment, man. You know?
And it's something that I think that
when people hear that, that you did,
that people realize like,
I can do that too.
And, uh, you wondering why
were these crazy Greeks put
pine resin in there ruining
perfectly good white wine. And then
after a while you start to say, Hey,
actually this is pretty good. Uh, you
know, this is not a crazy thing after all.
And you acquired case run resident
and there were walls. Yes. You know,
the first time, the first time
I had scotch whiskey, I, I,
uh, I didn't know what I thought about
it. And now I love whiskey. Right.
It's an acquired taste. So the first
time you drink something like that,
you think, you know, yes. They put resin,
they put pine resin in their white wine.
The chill it.
I should have brought you some,
maybe I'll send you on an acquired taste.
Ouzo Koolaid.
It's delicious from the beginning.
Yeah. I just write out cold.
It's a sweet good. Yes, yes, yes.
We'll have to convince anybody.
Yes, that's right. That's right.
Some things that's right.
Some things are just good right
out of the budget is good. Yes.
Koolaid is just good. Yeah. I mean, I
don't recommend you drink it all the time.
It's full of sugar. It's terrible for
you, but damn, that stuff tastes good.
It's like, it's like a, it's like
fried foods, you know? Yeah. Yummy.
A lot of them French fries. Yes. I mean,
come on man. Salt and catch up like that.
How can you know?
I'm uh,
I'm not sure about what I should mention,
but anyway,
I love Popeye's fried chicken. Can I do
as well? I love it so bad. It's awful.
It's my wife. My wife is unlikely to
listen to this full podcast, so, or I'll,
I'll skip over this part so
she doesn't hear this part but,
and my sister will be listening probably
and so she will laugh when she gets to
this part because whenever I see my eyes
I just pull over and indulge myself and
then I terrible. Terrible. It's
awful. This is good. You know what,
if you really want to indulge and
you like chicken Roscoe's in La,
I have it. No, you don't know. Oh, I
don't know. Ascos chicken and waffles.
Oh Dude. I tried to go the chicken
and waffle family. We tried.
Don't you make that tried to go there
the other day with my family and a half.
Wait on the same place. Sunday chicken
and walls course on the same plate.
What are you a communist? Yeah, man,
it's La Syrup and butter.
Yeah.
You mean put it on
there? Yes. It perfectly.
It's not damn delicious in my
mind yet from another pant I,
I make maple syrup.
I live in Vermont and I make Maple Syrup.
I tap my own trees and wow. What a
freak I have. I have a yeah, exactly.
Even people hard time for waffles
and chicken again. Exactly what is,
show me the colonel. The
colonel is a liar. He does
not have it. Get out of here.
It's not even the colonel, the
colonel's norm Macdonald. I saw a
promotion or something that this is
yeah, but they do not, oh my gosh.
I walk from the syrup goes on top of
the chicken. That chicken and wild,
that waffles and chicken tastes like
cat litter compared to Roscoe's is also
sweet chick La. He could try to
get this out of here. Uh, so, uh,
it's stuff can go fuck off.
Roscoe's chicken and waffles. Okay,
so you get the Greens to the Collard
Greens, Collard Greens. Yeah, that's fine.
Damn good. That's fine. But
that's a waste of maple syrup.
Take it from a man who makes it up to
put it on a show. Me a chick is good.
I'm source sweets. It's not as as place.
I get it. I love it. I've been there.
It's great. Roscoe's okay. Fuck off.
There's a reason why there's an hour
and a half wait on a Sunday. Okay.
How long you in town for a just a day.
Maybe I'll be back though.
I'll be back over there
right after the show.
Maybe I'll go there for a
little one on Gower. Okay.
Ooh Man. It's good. All right.
Maybe I'll try that. It's so good,
but it's also one of those places.
It's been there forever.
We used to get it.
I found out about it from 19 or
1994 when I was doing news radio.
95 ish, I guess. Have you been in La
since you left the Massachusetts? No,
I went to New York for a couple of years,
then I moved down here,
moved down here in [inaudible] 94 okay,
so you've been here a long time. Yeah.
And when I was on news radio,
they got it for like you,
you can order lunch and someone
ordered Roscoe street became addicted.
And I was like,
what is this like waffles?
And it was just like you waffles and
chicken there. It looks. That's, that's,
that's doesn't look as good
as it looks when you're there.
When you're there and you smell
it. It's damn good. I'm doing a,
Roscoe is commercial here.
That's an incredible, I'm a fan.
That's an incredible
combination of items to say, oh,
it's so good. And afterwards you
better have nothing to do, man. Yeah.
Going into a food coma son. Anyway. Um,
how do we get to that?
W W I don't know.
I was going to tell you
maple syrup stories. Oh yeah.
Going to different countries,
different countries and opening
your mind so you raise it. Yeah.
So you are counteracting my resin flavored
white wine with the Maple Syrup Syrup
and grass chicken.